In this video, we'll explore the Unreal Engine modeling tools.
The Unreal Engine modeling tools are becoming a more and more robust one-stop shop to make a wide variety of changes to your model once it's already made its way into Unreal.
You can repair mesh problems or even add new meshes entirely without going back to your DCC app.
Some of the things you might adjust would be selecting triangles individually or by material or by element or by smoothing group,
then changing the faces, the normals, changing your material elements so that different triangles are using different materials,
and you might even change something like your pivot point.
In order to use the modeling tools editor mode, you simply need to make sure that the checkbox is on in many of the templates it is on by now.
And yes, you can see there's a number of editor modes, including a more robust static mesh editor modeling mode,
hair modeling, and then of course we now have skeletal mesh editing as well.
Oftentimes when importing our FBX data, we'll see that the pivot point is not where we want,
and there's a very straightforward way to adjust exactly where the pivot point will go in a way that will affect all assets in the project using that particular model.
We have a wide range of different features available to us in the modeling mode, starting with how we select which triangles we would like to operate on.
Just in the select tools, we can invert, grow, or shrink our selections, we can flip our normals, we can delete or separate triangles from the rest of the mesh,
and then if we plan on going back to a group of triangles over and over again, we can create various polygroups.
Once we have triangles or polygroups selected, you'll see a number of familiar tools available to you such as extrude, inset, cut faces, flip faces, and many more.
Another handy feature is the ability to select a set of triangles, add a new material index or element, and then assign that material to the triangles that you've selected as a new active material.
To take a brief look at modeling mode, let's go into our content drawer, filter by static meshes, and let's type in forklift underscore LOD,
and bring in a couple versions of this. We can also just hold down alt and copy them.
The reason I'm doing this is to demonstrate that in modeling mode, when we save an adjustment to a model, it's not just for that instance, it will be for all three of them.
So let's say, for example, that we wanted to bevel this out a little bit and change the material. In fact, add an entirely new material.
There's only four here right now. What we could do is go into modeling mode, which also has a shortcut of shift F5.
And from there, we could start by going to select, try select, press down on our bracket to change the brush size.
I might need to change my camera speed a little bit here. And let's just grab that.
From there, if we'd like, we could create a polygroup just to make it a little bit easier to select.
And from there, we can go to polygroup edit, which then gives us a variety of different face editing tools.
So we can select our polygroup. And in fact, we actually have bevel as one of the options for what we're going to do here.
So once we click bevel, it immediately starts to create something that looks a little nicer than the hard edge that was there.
And if we want, we can kind of scrub up and down exactly what that bevel will look like.
We can even add additional subdivisions and also decide just how round we want it to be.
Try to zoom a little closer here without clipping to kind of see our options.
So depending on how much you're fine tuning this, do this to a taste.
And we're going to set this to material ID 5, which doesn't exist yet, which looks a little bit confusing, right?
We're not going to see anything there yet. So I can go ahead and accept action.
And we know it's there, but it's invisible because it's using a material ID that doesn't exist.
And we can say accept. And we see it's there, part of the geometry.
And now we're going to go down to attributes, edit materials.
We probably could have done this first, but that's okay.
So we're going to add a new materials in this array of materials from there.
Let's just type in the word red and find anything that might work for this particular use case.
M I metal red, sure. Great.
And so we see that that's going to come up right away because we had already assigned our bevel there to material ID 5.
Even though we haven't actually accepted it yet, it doesn't exist in our model yet, but it's here.
And now all we need to do is select this here.
Make sure that our active material is that new 5 M I metal red.
And then down here, we're going to say assign active material.
There we are. Now we can hit accept.
And we can get out of modeling mode and confirm that we applied this nice metallic bevel to our wheel there.
And we can see we've got this nice bevel here.
And we can see that this has in fact been added to our other objects.
Very exciting.
In the next video, we'll take a look at light maps and their UVs.